cool so so welcome so sounds like a lot
of folks like we're looking at my
profile ahead of time but let me just
introduce myself a little bit I'm you
know been in LA for about 12 years now
doing a number of different startups you
know right now I'm a CTO of Retina AI
we're doing artificial intelligence for
another one of those buzzwords for
marking analytics but our our web app is
written in view I've been a long time
you know web developer like leading
barrassed engineering teams but
switching between the number different
languages and frameworks like going way
back I wrote things in CGI scripts
that's for people even know what that is
anymore you know it's all server-side
generated websites that was a way back
in the day did things with Java PHP was
a big proponent of that definitely a lot
of server-side things so they say about
maybe eight years ago or like you know
2010 2011 or so JavaScript really
started you know coming back right it
used to be this thing that like you know
always broke so like you want to write
as a little of your code in it as
possible because all the browser's were
we're doing things and a little crazy
but then jQuery came up and then finally
like everything could actually be
written in JavaScript and so I
who here has written things in jQuery oh
wow okay so you're all battle-scarred
all right I mean it was great for the
time I mean otherwise you wouldn't have
been able to do things like in
JavaScript so you could change things on
the page without like a full page
refresh you know server-side so you
wanted to change that's one thing over
there you could just go and select that
ultimate and go ahead and change it you
could actually build in nice user
validation things where based on what
people were doing you know they were
able to immediately see some sort of
like you know were they doing it right
you have to get to the end of the form
and then hit submit and then figure out
that oh no I need to fill out all all
over again so anyway so Jake was great
one of things I built
jQuery and this was unfortunately
proprietary was a framework on top of
jQuery that I think did it right there's
a lot of things repeated people were
doing wrong with jQuery where you try to
select into the Dom and try to like
store your state in the Dom and do all
sorts of wonky things like that non
unidirectional flow but definitely
having a controlled event loop having
things be declarative within the HTML
itself writing HTML and HTML that that's
what this framework did it was
specifically for lead generation you
would end up with a single page app that
would like to show you one page and get
validated put some inputs show you
another page that sort of thing anyways
that was great and then I discovered
angular angular is like wow like I don't
need to build this thing myself right
it's actually a single page app that can
actually manipulate all this stuff
angular has been you know a great great
time saver great product everything I
think for a lot of the folks in the room
I saw who raised their hands
about it earlier you know it had a steep
learning curve and there's definitely
some abstractions that people are it's
easy to get wrong but you know a really
powerful language then came long react
right sort of jumped on board with that
as well getting it so we get some
performance actually you know we had
like some large pages that had lots of
reports and lots of information on it
and they get pretty slow Alice again
some past companies so react actually
helped to inject a lot of performance on
there make it a lot simpler to do that
application and in the same space kind
of what started doing things in a node
on the backend try to get the same that
we're doing the front end in the back
dude bündchen python current companies
doing a lot of things that are I do a
whole bunch of later languages I feel
like you should use the right one for
the right tool and geek out later people
really want to about different different
types of ones that are doing different
things I'm also a big fan of a
typescript as well in there in the right
context it can bring a lot of a lot of
efficiencies to how you're coding
anyways then it's covered view a little
more than a year ago and you know it's
kind of like looking at it with some my
previous company as something we might
switch to and then I end up founding
that my current company and kind of like
jumped whole hog into the whole thing
and it's been really great ever since
cool so what is you well so like why why
Zelda's hype right so it's actually been
getting a lot of popularity you'd see
actually that it's just sort of
neck-and-neck with react these days and
in terms of github stars angular sort of
worked itself or whatever they did so
like there are things they got
distributed but it's actually it got
really popular in 2017 the beginning of
the year there that's when like things
really took off 2016 is when the larval
community picked it up as they're
they're dedicated front end but view it
was created not out of one of the big
tech companies even knew who created
view was a former Googler but he wasn't
at Google when he was doing it the idea
is that rather than say Facebook's you
know doing react or Google during
angular it started from the beginning as
a community effort and even though it's
gotten corporate sponsorship since then
you know so Alibaba and Baidu or
actually paying you know some of them to
use a salary you know where to cut them
have them kind of work on that it's been
adopted by like Adobe and IBM you know
various large larger tech companies so
what is you well it's a view Oh
obviously done we're done all right it's
a view layer and so it fits in the same
space where react does right and where
angular 2 and above is trying to be
although it's wiring a bunch of other
things in addition to that and so the
idea is that it's about everything that
you do that's interacting with what
people are seeing on their screen right
how it appears they're in a nice
unidirectional flow you start from just
one place and you control everything
that's going on the screen
you you have a nice standard way of
handling user interactions you know
different events they might do click
events you know touchscreen events all
that sort of thing and so starting after
react view was also able to take
advantage of lot of the lessons learned
from react so so we got things like the
virtual Dom yes so the virtual Dom is
what makes these single page apps a lot
faster than they used to be for all the
folks in the room who were jQuery
developers imagine you you had a whole
list of like a 500 items and then all of
a sudden I don't know you wanted to
change the color of all of them or
something you might need to go and
select each one of them and change the
color rental on all of it you have to
figure out you know how to do that or
you might end up destroying all the
elements and then recreating them all
over again the the browser doesn't like
that sort of thing it's kind of
heavyweight to change things and create
and destroys all sorts of Dom elements
especially select them all the time so a
virtual Dom helps to make that a lot
faster by maintaining a model of what is
there and it only changed what it needs
to do to get where it's going to go this
is definitely what came out of react and
viewed that jump wholeheartedly into
that it also did it in a universal app
style so the idea is that you're able to
do server-side rendering of your HTML
just as you do in the browser so it's
sort of what everyone assumes these days
in there you know angular 4 5 or their
react 16 or whatnot but you know it
definitely was an innovation at the time
and it's helped people to do you know
build workflows where say your HTML is
generated via via node code like taking
in some state generating that and
outputting it as a template you can even
send it completely non web related we
generated like some emails using
you know node in the past for some other
companies so just no no browser is
involved so helps with testing
it helps with of course the universal
apps a universal app being something
where you write your pages and they
render sometimes on the server so that
what gets shipped to the user is HTML
and that renders as fast as possible or
things which are rendered within the
browser so that the the users has as
fast and it's responsible and
experienced as possible
cool so we're so that's how it gets fast
I mentioned this simple one-way data
flow would be something where you're
trying to control something on a on a
website and you're trying to specify
let's see these lists of lists of items
on on the website right and then you you
have some reason to change the reorder
them you want to sort them in some
different order for example or you want
to add an element in the middle right
what you could definitely do is get rid
of all of them just regenerate it all
from your data but that would be
expensive so what you'd rather do is
you'd rather go through the view layer
and say like here's my data I just
mutated my data and you will just take
care of making it look the way it's
supposed to look so is that guys evolved
dealt with this sort of thing before I
think some of you all right HTML like
templates this is the thing that really
everyone who's coming from react really
loves about view at least the ones who
maybe we're always a little bit
uncomfortable with JSX files I've never
really never sat well with me to write
your HTML in javascript in JavaScript
and that and have to do things like not
have your for you know in a label like
label for something or other not
actually refer to that because well for
is a keyword in JavaScript
so you can't do that it always seemed
wrong to mix one language with the other
language being someone who is like
learned a number of different languages
I like HTML to be HTML Javascript to be
JavaScript that sort of thing
it's just a clear way of thinking about
it so I've been blabbing for a little
bit let's talk let's look at some code
here so this is an example of a view app
what it's doing here is it's making this
thing on the bottom here where you can
start changing that and you can save it
and do that sort of thing so this is
just some jsfiddle do note this is on an
earlier version of you but it kind of
deconstructed a bit so I think it makes
a little bit easier for people to see I
know that wasn't me it was just this guy
anyways so let's let's talk about what's
what you're seeing here so in in the
view component here so this is the this
is a a view template I mentioned it
looks just like HTML what makes this
magic here is this this ID the app ID
here that's the reference that in this
case view 1 is hooking into and it's
hooking into the element and thus
everything inside of that div is now
controlled by view the the other thing
we're doing here is we're defining a new
new component within view and so a
component is you know the HTML and the
JavaScript that makes it do its thing
all together and so that's what's going
on here this is the template ID item at
it and this is just one of these little
lines here the idea is it has some sort
of list item that it's displaying you
see in the span and the the actual part
which is a thing displayed is the item
name right so each item is being output
there one can do nice little filters as
well sort of like you know my filter or
whatnot at that point in order to
transform it okay so and what you're
seeing here is you're seeing sorry this
is a older older view syntax your view
well these show can do a V if
that VL sort of thing but the idea is
you're only showing this particular
stand if that property in edit is not
true right and the other one if it is
true then you're going to show and in
edit screen so that's this is in edit
this is true and then now it's uh it's
false cool so you know that's the idea
of it being unidirectional the idea is
that that the templates are just
listening to some state and you're just
changing the state you're not looking at
all the things that are listening to it
so you can generate additional items
that we're looking for in edit and
whatever was modifying in edit didn't
have to worry about that great so now we
have here we're getting to the actual
click Handler and so that's what's
actually showing is either the save or
edit link that we're doing so the idea
is that it's a so this is connecting
into the click handler in JavaScript the
app click yes see that oh there we go
cool awesome
all coding should be done in the dark I
guess is that all right cool so and what
is doing here is the so it's preventing
the default thing that you'd normally do
with link normally when there's a link
it would try to navigate but it's
disabling it here and the idea that's
calling this toggle Handler and so in
our view component we have a toggle
method and what that's doing is it's
just well toggling the United State so
that's exactly what's going on here
whenever I click one of these it's
talking each one of them notice that
each one of them has its own separate
stage that's actually being what's being
defined here in the data attribute these
are the data for that component and it's
just a single boolean which starts off
false so view components all right so
you components are a nice view
innovation where they do exactly you
know every web developer knows those
three things HTML CSS and JavaScript so
why not like put it all together and
make it something that's part of your
view framework because they all affect
it in different ways right so the idea
in view is that you can combine all of
them into a single dot view file that
might get some folks who have been maybe
used to having their CSS BL separate in
a separate file feel a little nervous
because you start worrying about like
you're repeating yourself right but
actually what you're doing is repeating
that component all over the place and it
can vindicate its own styles however it
wants to in the react community and now
with the sermon is a later angular
things they've been adopting up
components as well some of the things
that's happening with view is they're
hooking this up with a web component
standard so that then wouldn't one can
take a standard web component and
bringing it as a view component and vice
versa it's not quite that smooth yet but
it's it's headed there so great so what
you can also do it with a view component
is you'll be leveraging those
pre-processors so in the time between
when we act and angular were first made
like this whole ecosystem pre-processors
has Brent up starting with say gulp
right we're getting well even older
there were some other things but goals
when it got easy and then webpack now
there's like roll up and and other sort
of pre processors the idea is you're not
writing in the code which is executing
in the browser anymore and so you can be
a lot freer to have your code be
structured the way that you want to
think about it and that's why there's no
such thing as like running a dot view
file just straight loading the browser
right it's just it's a source it's not
actually the executable code so we do
lose a little bit of that but there's a
nice set of like debuggers and tools for
stepping through things that it doesn't
tend to be a problem react in angular by
the way these days do the same thing all
modern sort of web development runs
through some sort of preprocessor
that's how you have typescript and hold
new languages that are created or people
are writing in es6 even the browsers
don't support it or some of the browsers
don't support it so cool so we were just
looking a little bit at the HTML
templates there's a whole lot of other
directives that it has the things that
would there be show and and whatnot
those are actually what view calls
directives and that's very analogous to
a an angular directive the ideas that's
a extra little bit of control that
you're attaching on to the different
elements that you're doing you can
attach different things onto it in
different ways and what you end up
getting is you end up getting like
super-powered HTML you start with HTML
and then you add this extra little
things on it and all the sudden it does
more all right just like we're showing
that example a little bigger though like
you can add that at clicked prevent and
all of a sudden you're hooking into the
click Handler you could add add a little
more code there as well if you really
wanted to a little more elaborate
certainly as a best practice you
shouldn't be writing all your JavaScript
in your HTML all over again because then
you're kind of breaking things all over
again
but it's very easy and very powerful to
do and to super power your h2no using
these new templates so great I will
mention that because view has decoupled
it if people want to they don't have to
use view templates to use view so if
you're already hooking up your whole
application to be view and then you
bring on your react developer who's just
gung-ho about JSX and has to rake JSX
they can write JSX and it can run in
view they can write a render function
and it can run in view you could write
pug formally you know Jade and and and
run it in view so the idea is that via
the power of these pre processors and
the fact that it's hooked in pretty
deeply with them you know anything that
has a preprocessor and web pack you can
run in a view component that's on the HT
HTML side on the CSS side the same thing
happens so you can run your CSS and just
call it a style you know
and you put your your CSS in there and
you're good to go but people have been
getting a lot more mileage off of CSS
preprocessors these days you know
especially if we're gonna do like nested
things are going to do a transform or
you wanted to find some sort of
variables like that set like the main
colors of your site or how you want to
set up your padding and your spacing and
your grid system and all that magic that
map that happens because you're using a
CSS preprocessor you can do that in view
I thought you can use it a little bit
here and a little bit there and you can
use your CSS here and can you just post
CSS there and then all you happen to
hook into this library that's using less
so you can hook into your less there mix
and match because it's all hooked in to
these preprocessors one thing that view
does that is new on the CSS side is
using component scoped styles and so the
idea there is that in your single view
file you can actually where you have
your HTML and you have your CSS all in
that same file if you add the scoped
keyword on to your style you will make
sure that that style only applies to the
elements in that particular component so
then you don't have to have really
really really long names just to like re
select the thing you're looking at again
this is like like them and whatnot like
I'm fan of those as far as like clarity
but imagine you didn't have component
scoped CSS you just had your CSS file
and then you had a whole web app over
here in order for this style to refer to
this element it has to have sort of a
globally unique name and there's all
it's sort of like you know rigmarole it
has to happen in order to do that why
not just put them together in the same
file and you just say scoped and that
style applies that with that element and
you're done so it does some magic by
adding on some extra like pseudo IDs and
things like that to make that happen but
it's it's pretty nice when it does work
there as far as you can make use of it
very easily and it mostly just kind of
gets out of your way one thing just too
if you are using a component scope
Styles
that's a little bit of a gotcha is it
can become a performance issue if you're
attaching it to just the type of element
like all your anchor tags or all your li
elements or something you should attach
it to classes and not to elements that
it works better in the browser that way
just due to the way that browsers run
CSS lastly so the last bit is of course
the JavaScript because you're running it
through a preprocessor anyways in order
to combine your JavaScript HTML and your
CSS you can basically do all the
JavaScript things so you can run es7 you
can run typescript one of the the big
advances it's been happening in view
like in the latest versions as they've
been adding typescript types so the idea
is that native View components and view
code will actually have types trip types
so you get the auto completion and the
validation and all the power of
typescript as you're writing your view
code and just like in HTML and the CSS
you can mix and match right you can
write this one component and it can be
in typescript another one can be in a6
the other one can mean is 5 wouldn't
recommend you do that but if you really
want to you can do that all right other
things here so the batteries are all
included
so because view sits in the same place
that react did just at the view layer
it's taken all the different battle
scars that react learned and just
basically copy done just wholeheartedly
just copied it copied it so basically if
you can do something and react you can
do it in view and so one of the big
things that came out of reactive of
course was of course the the flux
related libraries for maintaining state
right
imagine you have a whole tree of
different elements that are going down
and you're trying to have one element on
like the you know right side of the page
here or left side of the page where you
alter something that's going over here
well you might have to
I mean store it at the top and the kind
of like have both of them pass it all
the way down through the Dom hierarchy
and that could get pretty clunky so one
of the things that if Lux sort of thing
can do is instead of trying to pass
everything in properties you can have
sort of globally shared state and the
idea is this a single way of
transforming it a single source of truth
a single place of reading from truth as
to what is going on in your app and so
there what happened in the react world
was that after they came out with that
flux then people were like well we like
that but have some rough edges so he did
it with Redux and then other folks kind
of started just like it dozens of them
now as far as different like flux clones
and different spins on it or whatnot
it's been nice that in view there's
basically one that everyone uses because
it's the officially endorsed one view X
and so it's really powerful and that
takes a lot of the same features that
you've gotten out of Redux you can for
example namespace your different states
you can you know attached your different
getters and setters and be able to make
things like fully modular it also hooks
into debugging tools so there's also
official view X view dev tools and those
will hook into the the view X data
stores so you can see them you can see
it how it's changing and I'll show you
that to you in a little bit here so
great that's your store and you have a
view you have another important thing
which is like what controls all of that
what actually executes all that code and
figure out what what components to load
on all that sort of thing that's a
router right so the the router goes from
the URL or basically external state of
the world and figures out like what what
you should be doing at that point and so
there's an official loader router for
for view and that's the view router
great everyone just uses that it's
really powerful it does all the things
that you would get
out of the react world and just does it
one way and you don't need to worry
about it being reinvented every three
months or something it's just the one
way that they're doing it in view in
addition there's a whole ecosystem of
other packages so I was mentioning a
little bit ago that there's the site
awesome view if I was going to do this
basically yeah so you you want to do
your data table like pick how you want
to do your data tables you want to do
your notifications you do how you want
to do your notifications you want to do
progress loaders great take your pick
pick your poison basically any time
somebody was doing something and react
they tended to be like oh well let's
just do this in view - and it's easy to
do that because again they sit at the
same layer and they're able to do it
but what you're getting out of all of
these is you're getting all the
simplicity and they build things that
view does as well so yeah I mean you
want to do your icon sets you whatever
you want to do your validation models
your basically whatever the heck we're
using some things for graphing for
example we're using high charts it's a
nice view high charts plugin that's
great you want to do graph QL great you
do view graph QL and there's there's
it's all hooked up and loading you know
all the things that people are doing in
the react world and and they just come
right on over to view so all right I
think folks get the idea there it's like
cuts so that's cool editor support
actually here I'm going to mention that
too so I actually use atom but there but
other people use others things so all
the be modern and well supported editors
have a view support as well
even even old Emacs users
anyways alright so yeah the idea that
means the power of open source of course
right and so you get all the syntax
highlighting
you'll get autocomplete all the goodness
to get out of an IDE nicely supported in
view so great alright so some of my
favorite pakku but my favorite package
is before da vinci code here is a nuts
jeaious and I've been it's one of the
even though it was a little hairy when I
started using it I jumped in early and
been getting a lot of mileage out of
next next is a view clone of a react
framework called next because you know
it was react so we still it made it into
view and what it does is it handles all
the the webpack stuff that for you which
can otherwise get a little bit hairy
when you're doing something that has to
be compiled the way that view does and
so you get all these sensible defaults
it just sort of works out of the box but
you can also go and modify things if you
really want your web pack build to work
this way and you would prefer this
minify err and not that one
and you really want tree shaking or
whatever the heck you can do it that way
you also get all those things that
everybody's been loving in the react
world like hot module reloading you edit
your code if it's saved and then BAM
your your page is loaded and and showing
that as well
you get server-side rendering and
Universal apps so if you're writing a
page that's actually performance
sensitive you can actually have your
what's first served to be the HTML and
that's actually rendering the actual
content to let the browser go and do its
thing load images all
sort of thing and then afterwards it can
a synchronously load all the JavaScript
so that any subsequent page transitions
are just single page transitions so it
doesn't have to go back to the server in
order to just navigate to another page
some of the recent things they've been
adding is a static site generator I
think everyone who has a blog or a you
know instead of using WordPress which
has hacked every other second you should
write a static site and have it just
serve HTML and JavaScript and CSS and
and not be hackable in that sense
anyways and so the idea is you can write
your your pages as a view app and then
you just tell next generate and it will
output static files you just like send
those up or poke it into a CI CD
pipeline or whatever whatever you want
to do and it will go ahead and load that
quickly I'll show you guys an example in
a bit
last thing about next is the what it
does as part of making it simpler is it
handles a lot of the routing for you I
really like this style where really
there's like two maps that you're kind
of doing is you're writing a web app
like two like tree structures you're
doing one of them is a URL structure of
your site hopefully you have a sensible
URL structure such that somebody could
actually bookmark the pages you're not
to a single page app being at all so
that like they're like deep in your your
app and they hit bookmark and then they
go back to it and they're just and about
the front page again right so if you
have some sort of structure to your rels
you're also doing things to your your
components and how you handle the
routing and you know ideally these to
sort of like go the same way well Nux
just makes that simpler
the idea is you place a file in a folder
and you have the folder called I don't
know blogs blog posts right and you have
your file within it might be underscore
ID dot view and the idea is that then
that would enter a URL that can be blog
slash fives
ten slash whatever it is and that can be
dynamically routed based on the URL to
that particular view page and just just
all works I'll show that to you in just
one second as I actually out let me do
that now all right so let's start here
this is a the way that next works is
just like how some of the highly
opinionated web frameworks are have been
working is that certain directories have
certain meanings and you just always use
those directories for their meanings and
thus if you're picking up one project
and going another project it's pretty
easy to tell that what your pages are in
the pages folder and that's what the
pages are rather than in source modules
I don't know whatever or something yeah
so uh yeah putting your source and disks
because that's wonderful anyways okay so
here we have a a view app you see the
top here this is a template this is the
HTML as you can tell this this is what
is this isn't the CSS no it's not the
CSS um this is the JavaScript part and
it's in a script tag that's really nice
and then there's no there's no CSS part
to this but if there was you just put
that in a style tag and you're off and
running okay great so the idea here is
that just by putting things in these
different folders it's automatically
setting at the Europe URL routes for
that so let's do that
so it is it's running webpack and like
knucks is actually compiling it and
running it and now running a little bit
of a local server in order to host this
page but kind of handled that all for me
and this is the the page loading in in
dev mode right now
so great here's the page and if let's
see for looking at this what's actually
happening is Oh interesting okay all
right right so what's what's loading
with all of this right is uh here let me
navigate to another page so I go to the
about page and you notice that what
happened was it didn't actually have to
go back to the server to do a whole page
refresh this is a single page transition
so it's a faster experience for your
users it's all happening just within the
browser great some other things you can
do here don't remember if the oh yeah
great so here you can see the state and
you can be incrementing it and all of
that spoking into the the view debugger
here we'll go into the code in just a
little bit here but you can see that
that's it's going hidden and changing
that and you get like time travel here
so you can even go back and see you know
if you kind of undo some of these like
what was going on and it kind of goes
back nice nice fun little dev tool for
for view alrighty so so let's get back
into the the app app itself here so we
were you're just looking at it but let's
maybe try that that hang go handle
increment part cuz it's kind of more
interesting when you're doing something
in the app right that is calling this
method here handle increment and what
it's doing is it's editing the view X
store and telling it to increment the
counter and then the us store and nuk
style is in well the store because where
else should stores be but in the store
folder and the stores
stores all over your global state in
this case it starts off the counter at
one and the idea is there's an increment
counter there and that's basically the
main thing there the other things that
the store is using is it's holding some
other information here that's another
part of the app we can get into that but
yeah this is this is view X is all you
kind of really need to do yeah all right
awesome
they have a nice picture I was just
trying to get to the picture all right
so normally when you just have a simple
sort of like app thing right you have
your actions just mutate the state in
one way and that changes the view but
you might want to get a little more
complicated because your single page app
doesn't just like take inputs from the
user and like you know from the backend
database you want to plug in a debugger
or that sort of thing the idea though is
that there's just a single way that this
is all flowing unidirectional flow you
don't go from your actions back directly
to edit the components you rely on the
actions to go all the way through to the
state and the state to to then change
the components themselves that sort of
thing
jQuery world you would have some little
jQuery method that goes and directly yet
it's things don't do that
so then then you can hook your dev tools
as I mentioned like the the view
debugger into all those mutations and
see all the different changes that occur
to your state you can also see your
state at that point yeah that's the
basic idea of you exit so this is like
the flux diagram as well right cool all
righty so let's see other things about
the oh yeah so here this is all you
really need to do so you're Jesse wait
view so I'm gonna make a new page here
great so I call it a template and div
hello great and then I can go back to my
app which was oh I just killed it sorry
it's
not happy with me what was I doing
was I writing some code onsen Wow read
the error message just to later you oh
there okay and that's recompiling that
and it's happy should be happy
great let's go to that go to and they're
great we have a web page awesome that
was really fast and all it says is hello
but the idea is that in order to add
something new to router or whatnot it's
just as easy to that as that you can
then generate other things like as I
mentioned like blogs and call this say
Aidid you and the fact that there's an
underscore there
okay great means that no errors great so
what I could do is go to blogs and
something and all of a sudden great its
routing to that in the in the actual
JavaScript part we would get past the
the params here which is actually the
the ID value and be able to then maybe
do a database
you know requests and whatnot in are
actually load the proper blog at that
point yeah or questions yes yep yep just
because there's an underscore or there
yeah yeah but anyways yeah so if you're
starting off on and writing view it's a
they're still adding to it but one of
the things that's actually been really
great about view is that and this just
comes some in part just from the way of
thinking of its original you know
creator is everything is really well
documented so if you have a question or
something you can actually go to the
view website and you know nine times out
of ten you're the answer to questions is
right there nicely documented with
examples and and all that so yeah that's
been something just from the get-go that
makes it really easy to adopt view cool
all right so let's see that was next
I mentioned beautify is some of the
things that we're using here it's a nice
you know front-end framework again comes
with sort of like batteries included for
all sorts of components that you might
want in order to put in your site and
have it all be material design friendly
since you're burning a bit of an
enterprise app it makes it easy to kind
of like just implement things to get it
done beautifies one of the more popular
material design frameworks on the
so if you were to do that way you could
also write your bootstrap or you write
your whatever you want to do you know on
top of you yeah but I've been using this
one and and you know it works quite
nicely also like next it's all post 1.0
so there these are promising stability
on that ok great
this one I made this and I'm actually
kind of a fan of it just as an aside I
mentioned I do lots of other things
besides web dev dev ops being one of
them and as much as I love Linux I don't
necessarily love SSH into lots of
servers and doing server e things all
the time when I'm just trying to write
my web app so server list has been a
great trend that's been going on in
industry in the past two years or so
where you just write your code and your
code runs in the cloud and a cloud takes
care of it and does all the things that
need to do to make that happen for
example on a website if you have your
website running via server lists and you
all sudden have much higher spikes and
load it just starts running more of your
functions because your website is just a
function to say how it should render the
page and then it will scale down down to
zero if you have no traffic and they're
not charging you for that anyways so you
have a high availability you have a high
scalability and you have much much more
efficient cost than just like running a
bunch of servers just sitting there idle
all the time
so one of the things that I did was kind
of like hook it all together so I have a
service running Express inside of
Oedipus lambda and Express is running
next and the next is running whatever
the view stuff that we want to do at
that point and so I have a universal app
I have something that like has a nice
local dev experience because knucks does
that for you you just saw that a little
bit ago we're like well it's hot and you
get the hot reloading and you get like
dev tools hooking into it and all that
sort of stuff and when I hit deploy it
goes into the cloud and there's no like
Linux patching to do and that sort of
thing it's just it's just running so
there were some tricky bits
and I figured out some tricky bits and
that's why I made the package sorry guys
can you read that yeah so on the left
here this is the next folder structure
with pages and whatnot at that point oh
actually sir package oh yeah yeah I mean
this is the template this is a view view
CLI template where it gets substituted
but what okay but the idea is definitely
because next is a universal app some of
it runs on the server and some of runs
on the client so you need to make sure
you're running libraries that support
that so for example you're gonna make an
HTTP request you might not have a window
object on node so how do you you know do
all of that you might use a library like
Axios is the most most common one it's
actually been bundled into the latest
versions of next actually OS it makes
you make HTTP calls to other like the
back end or whatnot and do so easily let
me just actually oh yeah here I'm
actually plugging into Axios at this
point and then having Axios go ahead and
make a get request to its back-end and
then it's returning that as data so I
didn't go over previously in a view
component how you handle like an
asynchronous request or handle like data
that's not coming literally from the
page at that moment there's really
there's another way we can do it where
there's a bit of a state of the page
that's happening here it's the message
value here and knucks is looking for the
async data and it's waiting for the
async data to come back before it starts
to playing the page to you and it will
then do is then populate the message
with whatever came back from the backend
and the message is then being the showed
in that component so because we're using
Axios this same code will sometimes
execute in the backend and sometimes
execute in the front-end
and the page doesn't care or know the
difference there is a difference in the
perfect pocket though as to why you
would sometimes you need to store
secrets like you know your database
password or something right you know and
so you want to put that in the front end
so you need a back-end that just is just
the backend and and so that's what this
is this is what's actually a an Express
router that's actually just handling
that particular route and not putting
that that one pick their output and it
could have for example pulled that out
of the database in order to return it or
whatever you wanted to do using using
node it's getting a little bit far
afield from our view world a little bit
but something that I'm using a variant
of this like in production in our stuff
and it's working well there again where
some gotchas so making the framework
help to take work rounds in the gotchas
[Music]
awesome there's that other things was
you know when can build it into a CIC
deep pipeline it you just have the next
build itself in its pre compiled form
and then you tell server list to go and
deploy it into the cloud and then you
know we can run tests in between and
whatever you want to do and just have it
all automated and because it's all
handled in this case by Amazon Amazon
you can hook in very easily to things
like cloud front so you get DDoS
protection or like you know edge sort of
like caching and faster page loads
SSO you know resolution you can put
there there Web Application Firewall in
front of it if you really want to get
paranoid about blocking traffic from
here and not there and and that sort of
thing anyways you can write enterprise
apps using this stuff it's cool
all right last bit here cool
so I mentioned there's a beautiful view
site with a style guide awesome view is
basically if you saw something
interesting here it's probably linked to
from awesome view because that's the
name
and um the some other things that it
links to but want to mention is the end
of this month view comp us the first one
in the u.s. is being held in New Orleans
there's been some view conferences in
the past but they were held in like the
region countries and other places I will
mention actually that view is actually
very international because it started
off with strong Chinese connections
because again Evan you it's a create
areas bilingual so you knows able to
speak and write in Chinese so that's why
you would get you know Alibaba and Baidu
sort of buying on but it's been picking
up in suddenly like your PIN country is
quite a bit if you do a little nice
little like Google Trends search map you
see it popping up all over the world
unlike where the US were tends to be
bigger on let's say reactor or something
like that so cool and yes I am the
organizer for the LAV UJS Meetup
so what I did when I was jumping into
things is like well I want to talk to
other view developers and I didn't know
too many of them so I was looking for a
meet-up didn't find one so I made one
and so I've been running that about a
year now and we meet alternately we meet
every month and alternate between on the
west side and in downtown LA I have a co
organizer who runs a space out of LA and
she shall hope to organize that one and
yeah you can find us on meetup calm so
that's the last bits and that's me so
thanks guys
I'm Vijay thanks for coming to the
meetup today I'm the organizer for
JavaScript LA I wanted to just
personally thank you for watching this
video if you found it useful I'd love
for you to subscribe to our Channel
we're slowly but surely making lots of
little video content for you guys to
enjoy and soak up especially if you want
to get better at programming I'd love
for you to be on our slack channel to
over 800 users the link is right here
jeaious join jsj oen if you forget it's
really simple if you have questions for
this meetup or you know questions you
didn't get to ask or because you
couldn't make it we'd love to have you
just posted on our slack group so if
you're newbie don't worry it's a good
place to go there's a lot of great
engineers all connected around La in
Orange County so I hope to see you there